سعر الدولار الى مائة روبل عقب
بدء الحرب الروسية على اوكرانيا
لم يسمعوا لها قط صوتا عاليا على
عكس ما يعرف عن اغلب محافظي
قبل الحرب بحيث وصل الدولار نحو
ستة وسبعين روبل في ثابت وارتفاع
سداد ديون روسيا البالغة ستمائة
وخمسين مليون دولار حيث تقتضي
في قراره. خلال عدة اسابيع تمكنت
مابيولين من تجنب خطر التخلف عن
وتدمير استقلالية البنك المركزي.
قدمت استقالتها فرفض بوتين. ثم
نابولينا عن بوتين بشتى الوسائل
بالترغيب والترهيب بالاتهامات
الروبل من هذه الحسابات الى
عملات اجنبية شرط ان تتم استعادة
السنوية عام الفين وثمانية عشر
واختارتها مجلة فوربس الشهيرة
زال يتهمها بالهدوء والنعومة
المبالغ فيهما ويقول البعض انهم
المحللون الغربيون ان نابولينا
التي كان والدها سائقا وعملت
اوكرانيا. تنتهي مهمتها على رأس
البنك المركزي في والعشرين من
وصول روسيا الى حسابات العملات
الاجنبية في الخارج. بعد ان وصل
المحلي خلال اجتماع مع الرئيس
بوتين حيث بدت شاحبة بلباس اسود
كانت مفاجأة عندما تمكنت الفيرا
مابيولينا من الوصول الى هذه
للعملة الوطنية الروسية لم يكن
من قبل. تحاول امريكا ابعاد
الدول المعادية على حسابات
روسية. حيث ان السلطات المالية
اوروبا. ودعاها صندوق النقد
لالقاء واحدة من اهم محاضراته
كالقادة العظماء. مع توسيع الدول
الغربية عقوباتها الاقتصادية على
استطاعتا وخطوات نابيولينا ان
تعيد الروبل الى وضعه الطبيعي
البريطانية عام الفين وسبعة عشر
افضل محافظة بنك مركزي في
البنك المركزي فمباشرة بعد الغزو
الروسي ظهرت في التليفزيون
وصارت مطلوبة لمعظم تلك الدول
التي فرضت جميع العقوبات على
منها على حوالي عشرة من البنوك
الفاشلة. شرعت نابيولينا في بناء
الروسي رفض تنحيتها وطلب منها
البقاء في منصبها بحسب تقرير
يونيو الفين واثنين وعشرين. غير
ان الرئيس الروسي اقترح اسناد
فرضخ الجميع لها ما كل هذه القوة
والصلابة قد تكون هي نووي
ولاية جديدة لها حسب ما اعلنه
مجلس الدوما ويبدو ان بوتين عازم
الروسية ستتخذ قرارات تسمح
للمستثمرين بتحويل الاموال الى
اوكرانيا على حساب سياسات وبعد
تأكيدها على رسالة البروش التي
طلبت التنحي عن منصبها خلال
الفترة الاخيرة. لكن الرئيس
وكما هو واضح كلها انجازات
للمرأة القوية. سمحت نابيولينا
وهو ما اعتبره البعض مؤخرا اهم
خطوة الاستعداد للحرب على
خطتها لسداد بقية الديون ان هذه
الديون ستسدد بالروبل دائنين من
اصبحت رئيسة وزارة التنمية
الاقتصادية في مكتب فلاديمير
نشرته بلومبرج يسعى الغربيون الى
التركيز على حركات وسكنات محافظة
الحالية في توفير بعض الحماية
المؤقتة للروبل. ورغم اتهام
واخرها وضع معدل مستهدف للتضخم
عن طريق تعويم الروبل الروسي
تسعة بالمائة قبل فرض العقوبات
التي تسببت مع الضجيج الاعلامي
لبنوك كبيرة بالاستيلاء على كبير
من البنوك المنهارة. وكان منها
الاسواق فرصة للتفكر في معناه
لكن نابولينا ظهرت بعد اربعة
رغبته في العودة بالاقتصاد
الروسي الى العصر السوفيتي
احتياطي نقد اجنبي جعل بلادها
ضمن اكبر خمس دول في العالم فيه.
اضحى النظام المصرفي خارج الخطر
ومستقرا بعدما اضعفته الازمة.
ايام من بداية الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا بدون بروش. يقول
كررت ذلك فرفض بوتين ايضا ما هذا
التمسك بهذه المرأة. حتى انها
احدهم في ثلاث نقاط اولها اغلاق
خمسمائة بنك روسي من البنوك
ضمن قائمة اقوى مئة امرأة في
العالم الا ان الاعلام الغربي ما
على تحركات رؤوس الاموال والنقد
الاجنبي الى الخارج خلال الحرب
من قيمتها. يمكن لاحد انكار دور
القيود التي فرضتها نابيولينا
وملامح صارمة وقالت بعض التقارير
الغربية ان نابولينا كانت ضد غزو
اعصابها وضاعفت سعر الفائدة على
الروبل الى عشرين بالمئة مقابل
ثلاثة من البنوك الخاصة المشكوك
في كفاءتها وشفافيتها. استحوذ كل
تضعها على ملابسها ويتابعها
الاعلام الغربي قالت انها تمنح
والدتها كمديرة باحد المصانع
السوفيتية تعد اهم ادوات لتنفيذ
الضعيفة وثانيها كبح جماح التضخم
من خلال فرض سياسات تقييدية
لتفادي الانهيار الاقتصادي حينها
رغم انها لم تكن ذات شعبية حيث
البنوك المركزية حول العالم.
يشيد بانجازاتها التي لخصها
قدرة وذكاء نابولينا تبددت خلال
الازمة الاقتصادية عام واربعة
الغرب لها بالجهل باساسيات
الاقتصاد الكلي. اعتبرتها مجلة
بوتين. لكن وفي عام الفين وثلاثة
عشر. تم تأكيد الفيرا نابولينا
الغاز لدولتين اوروبيتين كي تكون
عبرة لغيرهما من الدول الاوروبية
فلاديمير بوتين الى الاحداث. لم
تتحمل صدمة تجميد الغرب لنصف
نفوذا سلاح بوتين الاقتصادي.
المرأة التي بنت حصن روسيا
شيطانة الاقتصاد. المرأة التي
يخشاها بوتين ولا يرفض لها اي
طلب. المرأة الوحيدة التي
يناديها بوتين سيدتي حارسة خزائن
دول الناتو الثلاثين تسعى خلفها
باقوى استخبارات في العالم.
احتياطات النقد الاجنبي التي
امضت السنين في بنائها ففقدت
عشر حيث اثنت عليها المديرة
العامة لصندوق النقد الدولي
المرتفعات. وبعد ان وصلت
مابيولينا الى هذه المرتبة اصبحت
الاتحاد الروسي ثم وزيرا
للاقتصاد وفي عام الفين وثمانية
المصاحب لها في فقدان العملة
الروسية ما يقرب من ستين بالمئة
عرفوا هذه الفتاة الهادئة
والمتواضعة خلال سنوات الدراسة
من كل هذه العقوبات بسلام. لذلك
لقد فرض لها بوتين حراسة مشددة
البنك المركزي الروسي والشخص
الاكثر شهرة في حكومة الرئيس
هذه الفتاة قليلة الكلام كثيرة
الافعال بالنسبة للكثيرين الذي
المركزي للدولة والذي هو جزء من
مجموعة ثمان. المخاوف من مدى
روسيا وبوتين لكن الى اللحظة
اخرجت مابيولينا بوتين وبلادها
وستين وبدأت سلم مراتبها العليا
في منصب نائب وزير الاقتصاد في
روسيا بسبب حربها على اوكرانيا.
صعدت الفيرا نابولينا محافظة
استقالتها مرارا وتكرارا. لكنها
قوبلت دائما برفض قاطع من بوتين.
انذاك كريستن لاجارد بطريقة
ادارتها للازمة فقد اتخذت تدابير
الاقتصاد والذي سيتسبب بمذبحة
اقتصادية للكثير من الدول.
الفيرا ساخبزا دوفنا نابيولينا
ولدت عام الف وتسعمائة وثلاثة
روسيا خبيرة الاقتصاد الروسية
وصفت بانها اكثر نساء العالم
المالي هي مستهدفة من ثلاثين
دولة اوروبية وتسعى وراءها
استخبارات عالمية لانها تمتلك
طفرة جينية ذات ذكاء عال منذ
كرئيسة للبنك المركزي للاتحاد
واصبحت اول امرأة ترأس البنك
مدت يدها لزعيمها كي تنقذ اقتصاد
روسيا المنهار. واصبحت هي من
صغرها. ادرجت مرات عدة ضمن قائمة
تصنيف اقوى امرأة في العالم قدمت
تعاقب دول الغرب بعقوبات
اقتصادية من اصبعها اوقفت تصدير
من لم يدفع بالروبل عليه ان يشعل
الحطب في منزله كي لا يتجمد من
البرد. فليس لدينا غاز او نفط
نبيعه لاحد الا بالروبل. مهلا يا
بوتين من اين لك بهذه الفكرة
العظيمة. انها فكرة الفتاة التي
والمدائح. لكن يبدو ان بوتين لن
يفرط ابدا بمخلصته وحارسة اه.